und zwar sorgt pleite sänger michael
wendler mal wieder für schlagzeilen
lange haben wir nichts mehr von ihm
gehört aber jetzt berichtet bild
exklusiv
dass der wendler seine siebensachen
packen muss und seine traumvilla
verlassen das traumhaus aus vom wendler
alles dazu jetzt
schnelle boote teure taschen schicke
essen von bescheidenheit oder gar
sparmaßnahmen ist bei michael wendler
und laura müller nichts zu sehen und das
trotz seiner steuerschulden in
deutschland die wendlers leben in saus
und braus bis jetzt wie bild exklusiv
erfuhr wurde der mietvertrag ihrer
traumvilla in südflorida nicht
verlängert das bestätigte die
vermieterin auf nachfrage für die
wendlers heißt es also sachen packen und
raus aus ihrem haus online wird das
mietshauses unter gordon angeboten vier
schlaf drei badezimmer und insgesamt
228 quadratmeter umfasst das objekt
außerdem gibt es einen pool und der pool
wird vom eigentümer übernommen das alles
gibt es für
6500 euro im monat aber eben nicht mehr
für den wendler und seine frau laura
laut bild informationen ist das ehepaar
bereits ausgezogen und das obwohl die
miete bereits beim einzug bis zum 30 09
2009 22 bezahlt wurde es ist der zweite
umzug innerhalb eines jahres erst im
vergangenen jahr verkaufte der wendler
sein haus in cape coral für
890.000 dollar und hatte große pläne
statt seine schulden zu tilgen kaufte er
sich ein grundstück um ein neues haus zu
bauen nach bild recherchen wurde bisher
allerdings noch kein bauantrag für das
grundstück gestellt dort finden die
wendlers also keinen unterschlupf
[Musik]
hier haben wir sprechen jetzt mit timo
berger ehemaliger geschäftspartner vom
wendler schön dass sie dabei sind sie
haben michael wendler noch im april vor
seinem haus in florida angetroffen
erzählen sie doch mal wie er da auf sie
gewirkt hat ja guten abend genau ich
habe im april noch bei ihm vor der tür
gestanden und
suchte ja nach wie vor das gespräch mit
ihm als er mich gesehen hat ist er wie
es bei ihm üblich ist dann ins haus rein
hat sich verbarrikadiert aber er wirkt
es schon so dass er sich sehr belästigt
fühlt weil eben der traum von der
privatsphäre in florida für ihn nicht
gegeben ist
wir sprechen gleich nochmal darüber
warum erfolg in geflüchtet ist weil das
hat ja auch einen kleinen hintergrund
aber erst würde ich noch gerne einmal
wissen wer mir eben in dem beitrag
gehört er ist jetzt ausgezogen weil der
mietvertrag nicht verlängert wurde
allerdings hat er schon bis ende
september gezahlt gehabt das hätte bis
ende september ja noch im haus bleiben
können was sind ihre vermutungen warum
er jetzt doch schon dann auch früher
ausgezogen ist also meine vermutung ist
da ich ja nicht der einzige war der
seine adresse kannte und es immer wieder
eben auch in dieser kommune wo die
gewohnt haben zu beschwerden kamen weil
dort eben unerwünschte gäste sich
eingefunden haben dass da auch an die
vermieter was angetragen wurde und diese
ganzen dinge die da herrschte einfach
massiv gestört wurde und ich mir schon
vorstellen kann dass die vermieter den
nahegelegt haben doch schnellstmöglich
auszuziehen beziehungsweise als sie
gesagt haben den verlängern den
mietvertrag nicht dass dann auch eben
michael sagte dann packen wir es hier
unsere sachen und verstecken uns
verstecken interessant das wort in dem
zusammenhang denn sie haben ja mal die
hochzeit für michael wendler geplant
sind dann so wie sie sagen aus auf den
kosten sitzen geblieben
er bestreitet das ja immer ein bisschen
dann gab es ein gerichtsstreit sie haben
dann recht bekommen wie ist denn jetzt
der aktuelle stand haben sie jeden cent
gesehen werden jetzt gehen cent sehen
bringen sie uns auf den neuesten stand
der dinge ja also genau das gericht in
hamburg hat zu meinen gunsten geurteilt
und also ich darf nach wie vor behaupten
dass michael wendler eben das geld
schuldet das geld ist bezahlt worden
aber nicht von michael wendler
zurückerstattet und ich habe zwei titel
gegen ihn auf seine us adresse und die
belaufen sich aber nur auf die
gerichtskosten und anwaltskosten
wieviel handelt da
ungefähr 5000 euro die hatte bezahlt
aber um die eigentliche forderung
natürlich nicht und da werde ich nach
wie vor nicht locker lassen ich war in
den vergangenen fast zwei jahren der
mehrfach in amerika hat mit behörden
gesprochen und wird das auch weiterhin
machen unabhängig davon ob es jetzt
wieder den wohnort gewechselt haben ich
bin mir sicher es wird nicht lange
dauern dann wird man auch wissen wo es
die beiden ist hin verschlagen hat und
da werde ich da genauso die behörden auf
die aufmerksam machen sagen sie noch
einmal peter konkret wie viel schuldet
ihnen michael wendler jetzt noch
insgesamt
29.500 euro staatliches unrecht drücken
die daumen und vielen dank für das
gespräch
bitte
[Musik]